like another day another dose of
disruption as border force staff
announced strike action that will affect
passport control at seven airports and
ports on Eight Days of Christmas the
people we represent who are striking
their Christmas has already been ruined
because 40 000 of them use food banks
forty five thousand of them have to
claim benefits the average wage is 23
000 pounds a year and yet these people
pay out benefits to the public keep our
justice system running our ports and our
airports and so much more the government
has given them two percent when
inflation is at 11 and actually it's at
16 for the poorest people that we're
representing people are desperate around
a thousand borderfall staff will strike
on eight key travel days in December
from December the 23rd to December the
26th and from the 27th to the 31st at
Glasgow Manchester Birmingham Cardiff
Heathrow and Gatwick Airport and the
port of New Haven leaving Travelers
plans up in the air 18th of December
Eurostar strike
um for the security staff for miti
um traveling to France
um next day I'm traveling back on the by
Ryanair on Stanford back to Stansted
potentially border Force for issues
Bart was planning to collect his
mother-in-law from Paris to take her and
family to the Caribbean I commute
regularly into London for work I'm used
to the recent industrial action but it
just seems that now it seems like this
waterfall of industrial action
particularly over the Christmas period
to try and hold
the travel companies at Ransom
a home office spokesperson said we're
disappointed at the Union's decision to
strike on the proposed dates which will
cause an inconvenience to the public and
businesses we're working closely with
all UK ports and airports and have
robust plans in place to minimize any
delays if strike action goes ahead
however passengers should be prepared
for disruption
the affected airports say they are
waiting for the home office to tell them
how it plans to mitigate the impact of
strikes on immigration controls but
Heathrow is among those saying they
expect to run Services as normal
although they could be longer delays
Manchester however says passengers
should expect some cancellations
the borderfall strike has been
deliberately timed to overlap with
industrial action by highways agency
staff striking on 10 Dates around the
country between December the 16th and
January the 7th and rail walkouts
starting next week all piling intense
pressure on government to keep the
country moving hard-working families
right now in this country are facing
challenges the government has been
reasonable it's accepted the
recommendations of an independent paver
body giving pay rises in many cases
higher than the private sector but if
the union leaders to continue to be
unreasonable then it is my duty to take
action to protect their lives and
livelihoods of the British public time
is running out for ministers and the
rest of us to land a resolution in time
for Christmas Paul Kelso Sky News at
Heathrow
well let's get some more details on
those strikes now and what we can expect
so border Force officers will strike at
the arrival checkpoints of six airports
and one port across the UK at Heathrow
Gatwick and Glasgow Airport they're
among the locations striking from the
23rd of December to the 26th then again
from the 28th of December until the 31st
NHS workers are scheduled to walk out
across four days ambulance staff on
December the 21st and 28th nurses on the
15th and 20th of the month in England
Wales and Northern Ireland and rail
strikes will take place as planned over
four days next week we can also expect
new strikes announced on Monday that
will start on Christmas Eve and run
until early on the 27th
with further strikes also planned in the
New Year while postal workers are
planning to strike over six days
and walkouts are also planned by some
Scottish teachers that's today and
tomorrow
driving test examiners security staff at
Eurostar and some civil servants will
also go on strike
this month